c'est un vrai bazar simon vient dire
être candidat alors maintenant ils font
carburer si j'ai tant m'échauffer pas de
problème mondial jo dix minutes ça
devrait aller au lever 105 et ce sera
parfait quoi je poste en cinq minutes
qu'a commis en fait t'es métallique
installée vous à vos places réservées
suivez-nous dans le couloir est montée
d'escalier
dépêchez vous non c'est n'importe quoi
ce que je peux faire je crois bien qu'on
a un problème il n'y aucun problème il
peut s'échauffer en 4 minutes et même en
2000 bon sens il a tellement crié quand
il est mis au monde qu'il a cassé la
moitié des vitres du pays avec la voix
magnifique
alors maintenant qu'on n'entend pas de
chanter devant le public il n'est pas
question qu'il se fait non c'est bon ça
va aller ça a été prouvé que j'ai pas le
niveau bien on rentre à la maison
bharati oui il ya des années folles
là ça y est c'est ta chance
quatre minutes c'est oui ou non c'est
oui